for
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in
authored by
the chapter of vigilance of
Allah's observation
the 62nd narration the narration of Ibah
[Arabic recitation]
his
huh?
What is his kuna?
Abbas.
Abul Abbas.
And his first name?
Abdullah.
And he passed away
which year?
Mhm. What year did Abu pass away?
[Arabic recitation]
after. And what year was he born?
Very good.
Ab
[Arabic recitation]
behind the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
behind him meaning he was riding behind
him and he said
this phrase
in the Arabic language
is someone who is prepubescent
age." This is what the term hulam is
used for. So we see here, huh?
[Arabic recitation]
us here how
roughly how old he was when he heard
this from the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam
that
he is
very young still at this time. And
the indicators that we would take would
be that this would be after he
later arrived at Medina
after the the the conquest of
Mecca because he he came with his
father. He didn't come on his own. Or
this could be in Mecca during the
conquest of Mecca, right? Which was, you
know, roughly in the year 7 after Hijra.
It could be a number of things, but we
know it was the later years of Medina or
the Med era.
He says,
for
[Silence]
Quran.
Oh,ch.
for
[Silence]
Khalima. for
Quran.
here he says I am going to teach you
some
words. Words here meaning I am going to
teach you some
rules or some
realities on life. The nature of our
existence. This is no small thing. Human
beings without these basic components
and without them believing these basic
components
the worst
will come out from the human being.
You can look at every foul action, every
foul action that a human being does.
every foul statement that a human being
makes and you can trace that statement
or action back to some belief that they
hold
that brings about that statement or
action.
Let's say a person
is doing bad things, a person is
upon misguidance or a person is
upon disobedience of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and they wish to correct this.
This really is a reflection of
a mistake in their belief, a
misunderstanding.
Whether it's a misunderstanding with
respect to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah tells us in the Quran that the
people of the hellfire
[Silence]
the people of the hellfire. What ends
them into the hellfire? What ends them
up there? What arrives
or or what leads them to the ultimate
fate of the hellfire?
Poor belief, misunderstanding,
poor beliefs with respect to the nature
of existence, this life, the next life.
bad thoughts or beliefs,
misunderstandings with respect to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. A person who
disobys Allah and is not afraid of him,
this is because they
haven't they don't know Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala properly. And likewise, a
person who has no hope in Allah and all
they have is fear that cripples them.
This person as well has misunderstood
who Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala roots back in
he roots back all of the misguidance
of the people of shik
and idolatry. He roots it all back to
what?
They have not made a proper estimate of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. All of it.
All of it. the worship of idols, the
killing of their children, the killing
of their young, theahish,
the slaughtering for other than Allah,
the worship of trees and rocks and
stones,
making faua in the nude,
the killing and murder of the
prophets of Allah, the dis disbelief in
the messengers of Allah, the disbelief
Belief in the day of judgment
belying the day of judgment. Where's all
of this come to come from? It all comes
from
they have not made a just estimate of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. A person who
wishes to better his actions must first
better his understanding.
That's what the Quran is then, isn't it?
And this is why
we see that a da a person who calls to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala who
hyperfocuses on actions
and overlooks.
This person has essentially put the cart
in front of the horse then hasn't he?
Let me ask you a question.
The people of Lut,
the people of Lut,
why were they destroyed by Allah?
All of them together entirely.
What was the main reason that they were
destroyed by Allah?
[Arabic recitation]
I tell you, we live in we live in a
place where most everybody around us is
disobeying Allah. Why aren't we being
destroyed all together right now
entirely? Homosexuality. Is that why
I'm asking what is the reason?
There's
something
correct.
But let me rephrase the question. Okay,
I'm not asking a rhetorical question
here. I actually want an answer. Right.
This is a two-way street here. Two-way
conversation. I interact with you. You
interact with me.
The people
of no,
why were they destroyed by Allah?
Has anybody here read the Quran? The
people of Noah, why were they destroyed
by Allah? Simple question. Huh?
What' you say?
Right. Disbelief. Right.
Isn't that what Allah cited the reason
for? What is the first thing that called
his people to?
But what about the people of It's not a
trick question. It's really not. The
people of
Why were the people of
the the people of what's their name?
Tammud. Correct. Yeah. Tamud. Why was
Tamud destroyed? the people of
that can killing a camel isn't going to
it's it's what killing the camel
represented
which was
the disbelief. What drove them to that
is their disbelief, rejection of their
message, right? Why was their messenger
sent to them in the first place?
They fundamentally rejected this. They
fundamentally rejected this u
this this invitation this belief of
worshiping Allahill.
So they were ended up being destroyed.
The destruction comes when messengers
call their people to Islam and they
reject and they reject and then they
turn violent.
And not only do they not accept the call
of their messenger, but they start to
actively prevent their messenger from
calling other people to Islam and they
become violent and attempt to kill the
messenger, start to kill the believers,
etc. That's the point of no return. Why?
Because now it has nothing to do with
misunderstanding. Now it's just just
arrogance and and just arrogance and
and hard hard-headedness, right? What
about the people of Hood? He was sent to
which people
and why were the people of Hood
destroyed?
same reason. What was it? Tell me. I
want to make sure that we understand
what the reason is.
[Arabic recitation]
what it is. What about what about the
people of
the people of Pharaoh, right? His
people, people of Alon, they were
destroyed in the in the flood. Why were
they destroyed?
Same thing. Rejection of
Okay.
Uhuh.
[Arabic recitation]
Th this these are details. We're looking
for the general reason why the people of
a messenger are destroyed. The people of
Quraysh Abu Jah Abuahab etc. Why were
they destroyed? Because
because their rejection of
the people of L. Why were they
destroyed?
Why were they destroyed?
because of their rejection
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
the issue is that many people will read
the Quran
and when a person doesn't understand
fundamentally the importance of and
the nature of the crime of shik that it
is a crime it is the greatest crime a
human being can can commit
They start to look at deeds as being
more serious than those crimes. Right?
The people of Shu,
they did other things other than ship,
right? They were bandits and they were
dishonest and so on and but they weren't
destroyed all of them entirely
completely because of that. They were
completely because of their unity upon
shik
and their rejection of their messenger
and the attempt to kill that messenger.
His people are no different.
is it
reasonable to believe that there's any
people you know throughout human
history
from the people of L on that have
dabbled in homosexuality or Zena or
murder or murdering their children or
these things are a stain on human
humanity and they will always be there
throughout time. But the issue is when
it becomes manifest and widespread and
accepted and no longer wrong. That is
the difference here. Eradicating evil
entirely to where it never ever ever
happens. This is this is never going to
happen. As long as el exists, as long
as the human desire for bloodshed and
for right exists, these things will
always be there in pockets here and
there, but they'll be underground and
they'll be rejected by society's
general consciousness.
Many people will make a difference
between the homosexuality for instance
or the the bandits or the robbery or the
murder and look at that as being a crime
that is greater than shik itself.
Absolutely not. Absolutely not. The
greatest of
acts that a person can commit that
will
warrant the destruction of an entire
people is their unity upon shik and
their unity upon injustice.
This is what has caused the destruction
of these right and that's why Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions that
pattern when we come to
the reason that we see those particular
bad deeds or those sins highlighted
and their shik anded not being as
highlighted is not because
Lord didn't come and tell them
aboutahillah
every messenger comes and begins his
dwah withahillah
every messenger that is the fundamental
dwa of every single prophet and
messenger the problem with the people of
l is that they had
continued to disobey Allah so much that
injustice
and
unnatural behavior
started to go so deeply in their com in
their society that it started to ruin
the fra itself.
So now good is bad and bad is good and
up is down and down is up. And how can
you call a people to Islam when you
can't even reason with them? We're not
even agree. We're not even in agreement
that up is up and down is down. This is
the fundamental issue and this is why it
is focused on so much more in that
story. But the reason that prophets are
sent is not to get people to stop doing
bad things.
It is to get people to
believe in Allah alone without any
partners. And once they accept that they
start to accept the rest of the laws of
Allah subhanahu wa tala and that's why
the da begins very general good and bad
right and wrong be good be just be
honorable be truthful very general
things and then when we see the
medin era what does it become it becomes
very specific
details
the finetuning of the general principles
that we have already accepted.
[Silence]
violence is
violence.